Let's turn to our menu example. And some people think that McDowell's Mansion of
Metameat is a fairly one dimensional restaurant, but they actually have not only
main dishes. What we sometimes call entrees, although, that means entry in the
US, I guess because it comes before dessert or because Americans don't know how
to eat. But in addition to main dishes, they have side dishes. So, this means we
want two different types. We want a type for representing a main dish and we
want a type for representing an appetizer. Whether or not you find Fried Python
appetizing is up to you. But the important differences are a main dish can have
sides, an appetizer doesn't have sides and a main dish is designed to serve one
person, whereas an appetizer may serve may people. That means, we want to have
an attribute for an appetizer that indicates how many people it serves. We could
try to represent all of this with one dish type, but that could get kind of
unwieldy, we'd have lots of code doing different things, depending on whether
its a main dish or appetizer. So, instead we're going to define separate
classes, one for representing a main dish and one for representing an appetizer.